What you're seeing here is
ScP-682 after undergoing a major mutation as a result of testing a new method of termination, which is currently redacted to unauthorized personnel
Only know is that it shattered the confines of its acid bath containment chamber. Which is now undergoing maintenance?
It has developed for large appendages that [can] be used for feeding
Causing tremendous harm to any one nerve
[but] anything within its reach in addition its Corsa was also expanded to accommodate the potential mass it can ingest
Before cameras started recording it consumed almost 6 D-Class in a matter of minutes
We can predict that 682 will eventually revert back to [its] previous form as with all of its other mutations
All we can do at this point is study its behavior and hope it doesn't breach containment lost in this state updates to follow
oh